cette unité
je
comme l'a répété sur place
posté derrière la tête maintenue à
genoux
[Musique]
tom qu'est-ce qui se passe cognac est
kidnappée et toi tu viens de tirer sur
la seule piste qu'on avait sur eux mais
la pluie du ciapol je dois vous avertir
que vous êtes diffusé à des millions de
personnes à travers le monde en ce
moment au kwat journaliste tu arrêter de
fumer
tu as raison quelqu'un a pris la fille
de vol qu elle est dans une fois
quelques paris elle va s'y noyer je peux
pas rester à rien faire
il ya parfois des gens qui meurent tout
le monde s'en fout tu vas voir je dois
continuer maintenant on doit continuer
les travaux les pas de rond tu as failli
mourir en essayant de sauver ton ski
puisque des fautes intelligentes règles
de base tu me laisse travailler et tu
parles seulement quand je te le demande
mais je veux filmer tout ce qui se passe
tu es mon frère
diffuse en direct
/ kg
ou est ce qu'elle répond moi
on a plus de temps à perdre
[Musique]